smell perception in mammals involves the
interactions of airborne odorant
molecules from the environment with
receptor proteins on the olfactory
neurons in the nasal cavity The Binding
of odorant molecules to the receptor
proteins triggers action potentials in
the olfactory neurons and results in
transmission of information to the brain
mammalian genomes typically have
approximately 1,000 functional odorant
receptor genes each coding a unique
odorant receptor all right
part a describe how the signal is
transmitted across the synapse from an
activated olfactory sensory neuron to
the inter neuron that transmits the
information to the brain all right so
let's draw this out so this part a so
let's let me draw the activated
olfactory sensory neuron so it might so
those are its dendrites there so I'm not
going to draw a perfect so those are its
dendrites right over there and then this
is its axon its axon and then this is
the axon terminals the axon terminals
just like that and I could draw other
details if I want I don't think you'd
have to draw all these details on the
actual test but just to get a sense of
things we could also draw the new Queen
to it in a different color
it could also draw the nucleus right
over there so this is the activated
olfactory sensory neuron so activated
old factory Oh factory sensory neuron
and let me draw let me draw the inter
neuron so the inter neuron so I'll draw
one of its dendrites right over there so
this is the inter neuron writing its
dendrites and then its axon
got a little bit better than that it's
axon just like that and it goes to the
brain and if we zoom in on the synapse
where we have to transmit the signal
between the two so if we zoom in if we
zoom in right over there we would see
the axon terminal of the sensory neuron
so maybe it looks something like that
and then the the the inter neuron right
over that just like this and this is the
synapse so this is a zoomed in of the
synapse and the activated olfactory
sensory neuron you have this activation
potential that is going to go down the
axon and then when it gets to when it
gets to the axon terminal right over
here it will trigger the release of
neurotransmitters so these
neurotransmitters are typically hanging
out in in these these vessels right over
here but then when the action potential
comes they will get released into the
synaptic cleft and then the the inter
neuron is going to have is going to have
proteins that sense that sense those
neurotransmitters and then that
activates that neuron so once again this
is the inter neuron inter neuron and we
could say that inter neuron inter neuron
gets activated actually it could be
inhibited as well but activated by by
neurotransmitters neurotransmitters
released into synapse released into
synapse by the sensory neuron by sensory
neuron due to action potential due to
action action potential and this is
probably enough but I went through a few
more pains to draw it out a little bit
and you could draw other details you
could draw the myelin sheath and all of
that you could draw the nuclei of the
different cells but the basic idea is
that the signal goes from one neuron to
another with the release of these these
chemicals these neurotransmitters which
are actually fairly fairly small
molecules but then they trigger the next
neuron and then after that signal goes
they get all they get metabolized by
enzymes and things and there might be a
few that just always stick around but
for the most part they signal from one
neuron to another and they could
activate the next neuron or they
actually could inhibit it as well but in
this case they're probably activate all
right let's do Part B let's do Part B
explain how the expression of a limited
number of odorant receptor genes you see
there's thousand receptor genes can lead
to the perception of thousands of voters
use the evidence about the number of
odorant receptor genes to support your
answer so one way to think about it is
and this is this is kind of a theory
here is that you you don't necessarily
have a one-to-one mapping between
odorant odorant receptors and odorant
molecules so don't don't necessarily
necessarily have one-to-one relationship
between between odorant molecules
odorant molecules and receptor proteins
and receptor proteins maybe maybe one
protein can can detect multiple
molecules maybe one maybe a given
protein can
detect multiple molecules or vice versa
or vice versa whoops I keep having
trouble with my little pen here or vice
versa or vice vice versa and so then you
could have this could lead to many
combinations combinations being D tected
so even though you could have maybe
these one thousand orange eenz they code
for one thousand receptor proteins and
so you might say well will those only be
able to detect one thousand different
molecules
well no each of those could detect more
than one and then and when they come in
different combinations they might
trigger the brain in different ways and
then many convert let me I could even
add that this could lead to many
combinations being detected which would
be different different smells in the
brain different smells as perceived by
brain perceived by brain now there is
some possibility that each of these
genes may be they could be coded into
proteins in different ways but they do
tell us
each encoding a unique odered receptor
so I like I like going with this one you
don't necessarily have a one-to-one
relationship each receptor could could
recognize multiple molecules or one
molecule could be bound by multiple
receptors and then the different
combinations of all of the above means
that you could have much more than 1,000
molecules being detected and especially
different molecules in different
combinations you could have thousands
upon thousands of smells quote-unquote
being detected